so today I'm going to talk about
arrhythmias which is involving the
electrical system of the heart
it's the heart that's no longer in a
regular rhythm it can either stop or
speed up or pound giving you all sorts
of symptoms from feeling dizzy chest
pain sweating a raising of the pulse
rate a lowering of the pulse rate and
there's a few more as well so one of the
big problems with arrhythmias is there's
not hardly any emphasis on the person's
diet what are they putting in their
mouth it's always about the risk factors
and they go right to treatment and that
whole system depends on these things
called electrolytes electrolytes are
electrically charged minerals that allow
the muscles to contract and relax and
the nerve to transmit communication
throughout the nervous system now the
actual pacemaker of the heart is under
control of something called the vagus
nerve and the vagus nerve comes from the
Latin word which means wandering so the
vagus nerve starts at the brainstem and
you have two of them they come down to
the neck and they start connecting your
different organs and there's that
connection to the heart that controls
the rhythm of the heart and that's part
of the autonomic nervous system the
vagus nerve is parasympathetic versus
the sympathetic nervous system which
actually comes out through your mid-back
that also connects to the heart and that
will speed things up the parasympathetic
slows things down but it also controls
the rhythm of the heart and the
autonomic nervous system in general
really needs vitamin b1 so the question
is what would create a vitamin b1
deficiency and you guessed it refined
carbohydrates okay refined grains sugar
that will deplete your b1 and that will
start creating imbalances within the
autonomic nervous system stress that can
affect autonomic nervous system various
stimulants like drinking too much coffee
or taking certain drugs that speed up
the heart and many drugs will alter the
autonomic nervous system as well and
many drugs will also deplete item b1 so
there are really seven things that cause
arrhythmia so you have the hypothyroid
condition which can cause a problem
hyperglycemia
that's diabetes or insulin resistance
and insulin resistance is a condition
which blocks the electrolyte absorption
into that cell you can also have
alkalosis okay which can be coming from
low potassium alkalosis is a pH problem
of the blood and you're just slightly
too alkaline and if your body is too
alkaline you can't absorb certain
electrolytes as well is if you have a
normal pH a lot of people that have
alkalosis also have a low hydrochloric
acid in their stomach and they have a
lot of issues with heartburn and
indigestion and GERD and if you don't
have the normal pH that you need in the
stomach you can absorb minerals again
you're creating an electrolyte
deficiency just from that so two of the
big causes of alkalosis is low potassium
and high cortisol from stress and then
we have something called hypokalemia
which is basically low potassium and
this comes from high carb diets being on
diuretics okay then you have something
called hyponatremia that's a condition
where you have not enough sodium in the
body that can be created by being on a
low salt diet and drinking a lot of
water okay because that dilutes this
electrolyte and this can interfere with
the electrical activity of the heart and
create a lot of heart problems then we
have number six hypokalemia that's low
calcium calcium is an electrolyte you
can also have arrhythmias if you have a
hyperkalemia too like too much calcium I
should have added that to the list but
this could come from not enough vitamin
D a very common problem then you have
something called hypomagnesemia okay
which is low magnesium another
electrolyte you can also have rythme us
from having gastric bypass because when
you bypass some of the colon
you're inhibiting the absorption of
certain electrolytes or if you have
malabsorption let's say for example you
have IBS or some type of celiac problem
or scar tissue in your colon or a
history of antibiotics if you have
damage in your colon you're gonna have a
hard time absorbing these electrolytes
eventually that can lead to this right
here if this looks complex it's really
not it's very simple what you have to do
is restore your electrolytes okay so
here are some action steps number one
restore your electrolytes you can
actually take electrolytes you can start
to increase the vegetables in your diet
seven to ten cups this will definitely
provide for the potassium and magnesium
kind of those two right there and of
course the sodium that's easy just add
some sea salt you may want to acidify
the body if you have alkalosis the tain
hydrochloride is a great natural
supplement you can take along without
cider vinegar to start acidifying your
body so you can get more absorption and
number three very important avoid
refined carbohydrates when you consume a
lot of refined carbohydrates you deplete
vitamins and minerals especially
potassium especially magnesium these
carbs turn into sugar they raise sugar
and you become a diabetic then you get
insulin resistance and now you can't
absorb these minerals like you did
before so you want to fix insulin
resistance if you're new to my channel I
put a link down below on how to do
healthy keto and in a minute fasting
that's that'll help you with this a lot
vitamin b1 is also important as well you
can get this from nutritional yeast you
can get in a powder or a supplement but
b1 is very very important in in
supporting the autonomic nervous system
alright guys thanks for watching hey if
you're liking this content please
subscribe now and I will actually keep
you updated on future videos